[Richard Hobbes]
Let me give you a piece of advice.
If you're gonna steal… steal a lot.
-Sir, the police are here.
-The police?
-Sir.
-Get your hands off of me!
Detective! Can we talk about this?
[Richard Hobbes]
I'm gonna pay you for your time.
Stop. He's not a cop.
This is what my son does.
He plays these games.
[Richard Hobbes]
All that work for 1,000 dollars.
If you're gonna steal… steal a lot.
-What are you doing here?
-Just wanted to say, "Hi."
-Not a good time.
-All right, cool. See you around, Dad.
I always assumed
my son would inherit all this.
He doesn't have the fortitude.
He's weak.
♪ Whoever said money
Can't solve your problems ♪
♪ Must not have had
Enough money to solve 'em ♪
You like him a little bit.
[Madeline] Of course, I like him.
He's a billionaire.
♪ Been through some bad
And I should be a savage ♪
♪ Who woulda thought
It'd turn me to a savage ♪
[Max] We're celebrating.
What exactly are we celebrating?
Billions of dollars.
[Max] Roll up your sleeves.
Trust me.
You can't cheat an honest man.
That's why we never feel sorry
for the mark.
[Sandra] I really like you.
I really like you, too.
You lied to me.
[Madeline] We're all human.
Just doing the best we can.
[Richard Hobbes]
You cause your mother anguish.
And I will not have it.
She wants me gone.
How do you think this ends?
Not well.
[Madeline] What did you tell him?
I'm gonna take a billion
dollars and aim it in your direction.
Sandra! Sandra!
[Sandra] Is this real?
[Tom] This is real.
How can I be sure?